peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
[Musique]
terre de paradoxes et de contrastes de
fête joyeuse et de mélancolique rêverie
des tubes errance et de pudeur mais les
demeures et d'amour confondues dans de
même histoire le pays basque par ses
légendes et par celle qui s'attache
particulièrement à son nom est la terre
de toutes les traditions sauvegarder en
dépit d' habitude niveleuse saura-t-on
jamais d'où il vient ce petit peuple
fascinant que voltaire a joliment fait
danser au pied des pyrénées
faut-il croire vraiment qu'il est né de
la transplantation d'écossé en espagne
par jules césar ou faut-il préférer la
version qu'il fait descendre de tubas lé
petit fils d y envoyer en péninsule
ibérique après le déluge afin de la
repeupler vaut-il mieux encore le faire
venir d'egypte
il faut il croire aussi qu'il a échappé
au désastre de l'atlantique un élément
peut-être pour donner une réponse à ces
questions la présence ici de petits
chevaux brun qui ne ressemble à aucun
autre
des poneys que l'on appelle podium sur
la frontière franco espagnole des
animaux qui semblent d'une autre hip hop
et plombant allègrement au marché
d'espelette et d'ailettes à quelques
encablures de l'espagne tandis que
chante les tweets schultz et les
tambours
[Musique]
par eux il est possible de penser que
les basques sont venus du caucase
puisqu'aussi bien ses chevaux rappelle
les sauvages montures des gens jce
campagne barroso si on peut croire que
les basques sont là de toute éternité
car ils sont au centre des dessins
rupestres mises au jour dans les grottes
de la région ou que l'on fait remonter
au paléolithique
à moins que ces bêtes redécouverte par
notre génération ne vienne tout
simplement daf est d'une heure à
l'époque où les arabes ont envahi
l'aquitaine remontant jusqu'à poitiers
il n'est pas exclu que la civilisation
ibérienne et jouer un rôle important
dans la génèse de la culture oscar yens
dès lors il est possible que les fautes
idiotes et est implantée chez nous dès
le 6e siècle avant notre ère
[Musique]
mais qu'importe tout cela importe leur
origine étroitement lié sans doute à
celle des basses l'essentiel n'est-il
pas de connaître et de préserver cette
race que l'on ne rencontre nulle part
ailleurs les podiums sont de petits
chevaux rust sont aisément
reconnaissables à leurs robes fourni à
leur tête plus grosse que celle d'un
autre poney alors encolure courtes et
puissantes à leur couple large et à leur
ventre arrondi
une mesure guère plus d'un mètre vingt
et porte et la crinière généreuse
[Musique]
en fait ils appartiennent à la faune
traditionnels basques riches par
ailleurs de sangliers de milan et de
palombes que l'on tire au fusil au
moment des grands vols d'automne ou que
l'on prend dans des pentes hier immense
filet tendu en travers des cols
pyrénéens mais la liberté dont jouit cet
écheveau a failli leur être fatal veut
surveiller
il n'en était qu'au mieux à la merci de
trafiquants de viande non scrupuleux
[Musique]
quand
certains veillait heureusement un homme
en particulier le cieux dutournier qui
s'est fait à ça il y a quelques années
le protecteur et l'historien de la race
[Musique]
dans le royaume des pottok vous voyez
ici ici connaissent et vivent en liberté
nos podiums sur deux compagnies auraient
kilomètres et des kilomètres
[Musique]
on
j'en appelle soit là bas et nous avons
certainement tombé sur un petit groupe
de podium
c'est un endroit idéal comme sur le plan
de la rue ils ont de quoi manger c'est
assez varié et surtout il a peur il ya
une source est très bonne très bonne
hier on aperçoit la joue et même un
petit lot de podium
[Musique]
et c'est là oui c'est là qu'ils naissent
vivent et essayons maintenant de lavage
d'améliorer leur sort en créant des
bergeries courir deux fois en quatre ans
que j'ai fait avec les moyens du bord il
montrait tout de suite fédérer bassine
d'eau il faudrait faire ça sur toute la
vente a entraîné des morts
[Musique]
il existait dans le caucase et a mûri et
je suppose que les brasseries boston
nous avons bien on a juste derrière des
labradors voilà des points tombant juste
répression nous avons dû arriver un jour
du caucase un genou à terre
peut-être est-il arrivé jusqu'en bas à
cheval sur ces règles
[Musique]
[Rires]
les portugais faisant d'être sauvée
parce que d'abord se sentent c'était des
bêtes et ce sont des extrêmes
intéressante qui naissent et vivent en
liberté dans les montagnes du pays
basque
ces bêtes étaient ignorées pratiquement
et autrefois pendant des probablement
pendant des siècles en tout cas pendant
des générations
hall est expédiée dans les mines ou ses
bêtes finissent leur vie ne remonter
plus jamais la lumière
par la suite les jours de foire
spécialisée comme la foire d'espelette
ou de d'ailettes on descendait à grand
coup de pied dans le ventre c'est bête
on les descend d et elles étaient
expédiées et racheté plutôt acheté par
les bouchers ou des matignon qui les
expédier dans les fabriques de salami
vers des fabriques de sa mamie ou des
boucheries ou encore gérard ou ailleurs
et voilà qu'elle était la destinée de
ces bêtes là
[Musique]
on
il y a une chose qui est magnifique
c'est que la l'enseigne campagne de
publicité énorme pour la sauvegarde de
ces bêtes
pour la sole est évidemment la première
affaire a été excellente parce que le
monde entier jup lire mais en tout cas
la france entière est intéressée aux
poteaux qui est beaucoup de pays
étrangers
des gens sont venus acheter des bêtes
pour les offrir à leur cause pour leur
reer à leurs parents pour garnir même
des jardins des des propriétés et puis
tu arrives et une clientèle à laquelle
nous ne pensions pas qui est une
clientèle il faut avouer que le cheval
est à la mode et le poney à la mode ceci
nous a énormément aidés et alors qu'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est que des
éleveurs de différentes provinces des
des animateurs de clubs de poney
d'orange chez tout ça nous ne se sont
adressés à dos et ont commencé à acheter
des bêtes
[Musique]
il est plus intéressant d'avoir des
pottok qui font près de 1 m 30
parce que des gens des garçons d'été
jeunes jusqu'à 17 et 18 ans peut
chevaucher des produits alors que le
pôle up le ch et la mena que d'accord en
être ou en mai 0,5
des gens au bonhomme en des pottok au
pays basque en pleine montagne et ils
sont à ce moment là toujours en liberté
il est commercialisé à ce moment là
uniquement si on peut dire brut
ils n'ont pas pu aller travailler parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas les attraper ou
difficilement
d'autres ont des élevages toujours par
troupeaux mais dans des endroits qui
sont fermés clôturé et qui sont amies
coteaux mios terre le climat est moins
rigoureux ils peuvent les approcher et
le cheval à ce moment là est beaucoup
plus calme et beaucoup plus doux parce
que il voit son éleveur il voit son
propriétaire il a un contact avec
l'homme il n'est pas pour chasser comme
il peut l'être quelquefois en montagne
[Musique]
car gardien du canadien tient la
boutique à tiens tiens tiens tiens
cabrio catia pour le côté bien bien bien
dit je tiens toujours là avec toi là là
le syndicat des propriétaires de pottok
à mener d'abord une surveillance avec
les terrines air avec le docteur
barnèche tout ça et puis immédiatement
en contrôle qui nous a permis qui m'a
permis a commenté le coprésident de
livrer des pratiques valable contrôler
et tout d'un coup nous avons découvert
qu'un tas de gens qui n'étaient pas
simplement des particuliers qui
s'intéressait à sauvegarde du podium
mais bien des animateurs de poney club
de dhr en dessous de colonies de
vacances et des éleveurs se sont
intéressés au podium et s'est avéré mais
très rapidement que le podium était un
animal très valable et qui était très
facile à dresser et actuellement on peut
dire qu'il ya eu 25 à 30 pour les clubs
au ranch qui sont animés qui sont
alimentés par le podium et qui font la
joie de tout le monde
il est certain que nous avons attiré
l'attention de la direction générale d
a1 et qu'on ne peut pas ignorer le poids
coq qui avec le poney landais elle est
le seul les deux seuls points des
français et chacun sait que la
fédération du poney la fédération
française du poney en france ne comporte
que des poneys étrangers les jeunes
éleveurs du pays les berges et les
pasteurs vous en avez l'exemple ici ont
descendu d'abord les haras locaux les
haras de pau en sélectionner des bêtes
est ici vous vous trouvez dans ces
prairies dans ces prairies dans l'eau
dans la vallée vous trouvez des postures
qui ont été ramenés de la montagne et
qui sont aujourd'hui vraiment dignes
d'appartenir à des éleveurs qui ne sont
plus simplement des bergers qui sont des
éleveurs
nous sommes devenus des éleveurs
[Musique]
en matière de conclusion c'est que nous
avons grâce à dieu brûler les étapes et
ce syndicat les bergers propriétaire le
pottok est devenue l'association
nationale du pottok et nous demandons
instamment à notre ministre de
l'agriculture de reconnaître nos
prêteurs qui sont un peu comme un peu un
peu particulier mais qui sont une race
magnifique
je pense que nous pourrons livrer
aujourd'hui une grande partie
[Rires]
ainsi l'homme aura-t-il finalement
réussi en pays basque a sauvé cette race
de son ignorance son indifférence sa
négligence avait condamné à court terme
comme ont été condamnés déjà les ours
dans ce même massif pyrénéen à l'heure
comme par reconnaissance les pottoks
sont intervenus à leur tour pour aider
l'homme à vivre une découverte faite il
ya quelques années maintenant a montré
que ces petits chevaux permettait la
fabrication du sérum anti lymphocytaire
nécessaires pour lutter contre les
phénomènes du rejet qui intervient dans
les transplantations cardiaques
une nouvelle vocation humanitaire se
prêtent à eux le podium payer sa dette
et si vous passer désormais par le pays
basque vous serez que rien ne menace
aujourd'hui ces petits chevaux qu'anime
de leur nervosité vite dompter les
places basque à l'heure des marchés qui
gambadent ivre de renaissance dans les
fougères dorée d'octobre où ils vivent
et se reproduisent en liberté alors cela
ne valait qu'il pas la peine de raconter
cette histoire
[Musique]
pour prouver
non non non non mais je suis promené moi
j'ai fait le 5 juin les élections
communales
si mal a eu du mal à la guerre des
juments c'est l'allemand régiment
bellera notre côté oui oui la pleine
bourre fameux la garantie
nous on est plus noir vous savez je dis
là qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire et tu
veux faire mais je dis oui au mois de
mai s'achève et tu voulais faire comme
aujourd'hui la wii de la société n'a pas
non plus dit qu'ils voulaient et si la
pièce est la monnaie c'est pas possible
et c'est pas pour ça
[Rires]
d'abord les 3%
depuis je mets en vtt 15 là pour deux
ans j'ai pas si ça va le faire mon coeur
c'est sûr c est que tu dois pas me payer
ma ce niveau là
[Rires]
la foire de relève existe depuis cinq ou
six siècles
c'est un lieu de rendez vous chaque
année de tous les éleveurs de la région
qu'ils soient du béarn landes ou des du
pays basque il faut descendre sur glace
pour faire nos affaires
je n'achète les autres vendre une fois
les affaires fait il rentre dans les
restaurants viennent à 10 et bien sûr
c'est un peu la fête ça finit par la
fête
[Musique]
chauffer l'eau libérée plateau 1
j'ai mon espoir est acquis rica au carré
vert mal aux haras national du mérite à
il est en bien mauvaise soirée tu as it
sous l'os favorita collectons cannelle
est la ligue 2 où elle a pris pas irina
inouk est bâchée rioche gamme bio sa rue
albert à richard serra et spain château
vélo mag rally a légué la fnaim erraki
n'daw et imane a légué la berra estime
hugo et mon show bien sâr l arabe air à
nigré bouchta et man down to capitalize
cher you want you came à issa dia mety
issa pénaux en audio
sankara et charles rousseau et le racing
ali soumaré capital et 10 jours à doha
rio
[Musique]